foreign
compound because it falls into this
category of what people call adaptogens
but normally when you hear adaptogens
first of all that's a very vague term it
doesn't actually mean anything
specific it means an ability to adapt
generally or specifically no one's
really pinpointed what that means but
typically the adaptogens are going to
reduce cortisol so for instance
ashwagandha is very potent suppressor of
cortisol there's some evidence it can
indirectly increase testosterone but
probably through suppression of cortisol
since those are in the same synthesis
pathway ashwagandha is an adaptogen
ashwagandha
because it lowers cortisol should
probably be taken late day not early day
because you want cortisol High yep
ashwagandha as a cortisol suppressing
adaptogen probably also should not be
taken in high amounts not low low
amounts but in high amounts meaning you
know four to six hundred milligrams
prior to exercise because the whole goal
of exercise is to trigger the adaptation
through a spike in cortisol or one of
the goals
rhodiola rosea's very interesting
compound because it's an adaptogen in
that it greatly reduces perceived effort
and allows for greater power output and
endurance output as you pointed out a
moment ago
but it does not do that by suppressing
cortisol
so 200 milligrams of rhodiola rosea
prior to say a resistance training
workout or even on one of your terrain
days you will notice you have more Vigor
you can just go longer and your
perceived effort is much lower and it's
kind of striking what is it doing now
this is interesting it's kind of
striking how after the workout you don't
feel as depleted that perhaps the main
reason I started taking is I found I
could train harder but then I suffered
quite a lot from a post-exercise dip in
energy especially if I ate big meal I no
longer experience that if I take
rhodiola rosea
I'm 30 to 60 minutes before workout the
effects of it last about four hours
so what's happening during that workout
it's clearly having an effect on the
central nervous system by reducing the
total amount of adrenaline that's
released or the efficacy of adrenaline
epinephrine during high intensity effort
or lung duration effort so what this
effectively means is you're in principle
one is able to generate the same amount
of effort without the same amount of
energy depleting neurochemicals I mean
epinephrine norepinephrine help you
generate energy but there's always a
trough afterwards always and so if you
can generate the same amount of physical
output in the absence of x amount of
adrenaline or norepinephrine then you're
essentially better off it also seems to
catalyze recovery better I would not
take it more
often than just before training however
because there are a few studies showing
that the effects of it can kind of taper
off if you're taking it all day every
day now would that be true for say
ashwagandha let's just say someone's
taking it before sleep would they want
to cycle off of that how would you think
about cycling
if recommended yeah low dose of
ashwagandha you know 25 50 milligrams a
day taking continuously no problem I
actually think ag-1 has low dose of
ashwagandha in it but when people are
taking ashwagandha to offset high stress
of you know mental or physical stuff or
both for a period in life I'd say after
about two weeks you want at least two
weeks off you really don't want to
suppress cortisol chronically unless
there's some clinical reason for that
yeah rhodiola rosea is probably the best
addition to my kind of
physical performance stack that I've
added in a long time and it's really
striking I mean I think so much so that
people could try it and it really does
seem to work the first time and every
time for me
if it doesn't work for you the first
time if you you know all other things
being equal you got a decent night's
sleep you're doing everything the same
way you normally would and you take
Rodeo Rose and you don't really notice
much of an effect
you know you might try and increase the
dose slightly and and give it another go
and what was the dosage range 200
milligrams 200 million is what I'll take
and I found that to be really striking
now I'm not going to take that before
like like a long Sunday jog or a hike I
mean I might but chances are I'm not
going to do it before leg workout I'm
gonna do it before a hit workout I'm
mainly doing it to
make sure that I can train really hard
and then go do other things really hard
too again that's not a competitive
athlete I loathe the experience of
training really hard and then feeling
like I gave everything to that training
session and therefore I don't have much
energy or Focus to give to the other
anything else yeah and I think most
people are like that are you still
taking the tonkat Ali and the fedosia
agrestis and for those who are not
familiar because I think we may have
made mention of this in our last
conversation but in brief what are these
two things do tongat Ali is an
Indonesian ginseng there's a Malaysian
version too but you want the Indonesian
one if you want to pursue these effects
which are it's known to decrease sex
hormone binding globulin which frees
testosterone
which is important in both men and women
it turns out in women
there's more testosterone circulating in
a healthy woman post-puberty woman than
there is estrogen Peter Tia taught me
this if you normalized for nanograms per
deciliter women have more testosterone
than estrogen healthy women do so
testosterone is associated with libido
ability and desire to generate effort
mood Etc in men and women probably the
best way to describe testosterone's
effects are
it makes effort feel good so Tonga Ali
frees up more testosterone so it mild
libido enhancer for some more extreme
for others increases energy will
increase you know feelings of well-being
and typically the dosages are 400
milligrams a day
in single dose or divide doses with or
without food taken early in the day
before noon or 2 pm because it can
increase energy you don't want to
disrupt your sleep there are a number of
good sources of it we can provide links
to a couple of those sources
and fedojia aggresses is a Nigerian
shrub it's taken from a Nigerian shrub
and it stimulates the release of
luteinizing hormone which is going to
come out of the pituitary
and in women will stimulate anything
that comes from Downstream of
luteinizing hormone in the ovary
typically estrogen maybe even
testosterone to some extent and in men
it will increase testosterone output
from the testes by way of increasing
luteinizing hormone maybe subtle
increase in estrogen as well this is
important men hear that
something increases estrogen they go oh
I don't want that well keep in mind that
if you flat line your estrogen so if men
are taking an astrozole or crushing
their estrogen their libido is going to
be zero yeah
their cognitive ability will be
diminished estrogen is important in both
men and also cardio protective isn't it
cardio protective the endothelial cells
we think of our blood vessels and Our
arteries and capillaries as tubes but
they're really tubes imagine Silly Putty
kind of rolled out Play-Doh made into
little flat sheets and then rolled up to
comprise those two so it's many many
endothelial cells that make up those
tubes and the flexibility of those tubes
is very important obviously you don't
want them rigid
that you need them to expand and
contract as needed and estrogen is
important for for some of that signaling
leading to that malleability of the
endothelial cells the dojo agrestis is
typically taken in dosages of 300 to 600
milligrams per day
with or without food doesn't seem to
matter if it's early day late day
there's some evidence that in rats it
can be toxic to the testicular tissue
but that's in very very high
concentrations and the it's interesting
the the number of studies on humans for
both Tonga Ali and fedoja have greatly
expanded since our last conversation
especially for tongali there's quite
good support safety margins are good
within the dosage ranges that we've
talked about I've heard of people taking
up to a gram a day of Tonga Ali that
just makes me cringe I think taking
herbal compounds in very high
concentrations it's going to be risky no
matter what because these things can
trigger immune responses so you know 400
milligrams of Tonga Ali 300 600
milligrams of fedocia taken daily should
be fine I don't cycle them and never
have some people cycle the fedogia why
they're afraid why don't I cycle them
yeah because they just keep working well
I mean Louie Simmons could have said
that about it right well yeah so a
couple of reasons I do blood work twice
a year yeah liver enzymes are included
there we can talk about fertility
perhaps it if you want today in the last
year because of my age in the fact that
I don't have children yet but I'm
cognizant of the fact that I do want
them at some point
I started doing I got really down the
rabbit hole interesting figure of speech
of sperm analysis including everything
from DNA fragmentation to out to
increase sperm numbers and motility and
quality and egg quality because you're a
Gambling Man if you're making your
swimmers world class but you don't want
kids
well it's all about readiness I suppose
what is it in the SEAL Teams they say
like you you fall not to the level of
your if you're open to your level of
your preparation you you do not rise to
the level of your hopes but fault level
your preparation that's actually a quote
from archaeologus who is a Greek poet
and I believe philosopher also but yes
also widely used in the Special Forces
teams so I've been monitoring sperm
parameters freezing sperm because I
might want to do IVF someday with
somebody you know this kind of thing
or have conceived naturally but and
because yeah we're talking about
tools supplements Etc as it relates to
vitality and fertility
I think there is a way to optimize for
both of those things so I don't cycle
them because I haven't felt a need to or
something I need to some people choose
to just take a week off from for doji
every once in a while or go five days on
two days off and people should do what
makes them comfortable males will notice
an effective for Doja it actually will
increase testicular size somewhat and a
density and that's just because of the
increase of the LH luminizing hormone is
going to stimulate avocado pits
it's going to depend on where you start